when you are training for a movie when
you were getting ready when you have to
be physically fit that you are
incredibly disciplined and I was curious
what's your secret what's your what's
your regimen what does Mark Wahlberg do
when he has to get in shape depends on
what I have to do for the job but this
laughter Patriots day where it's funny
because Pete and I we did the water
horizon want to be as heavy and out of
shape as possible right then we're gonna
do this movie that he wanted me to
invest shape of my life I trained for a
hundred days quit drinking everything he
said no I don't want to do that now I
want to do Patriots and I want you to
get heavy again so I had to put on
weight again for that that I had
transformers so basically I'm up at 3:30
in the morning eating breakfast training
for an hour and a half cooking a chicken
while my kids are eating breakfast and
then I run the golf course I play golf
for an hour 15 minutes before my golf
can you play in an hour and 15 minutes
all 18 holes cuz I actually got an 18 18
holes his eyes at four hour and a half
hours five hours those are guys that
don't want to go home right guys you
wanna go home guess and my wife is
beautiful so yeah reason to go I want to
go home right um but no I play first so
if you play first off and you play with
like just one other guy we can I can
play I've played in an hour in five
minutes wait a minute do you even get
out of the golf cart are you just
driving yeah no I'm whacking the ball no
it's not like polo no I get out and hit
the ball I just don't spend too much
time milling about you know I got the
yardage my rangefinder I hit the ball
and I go on to the next shot and yeah
and then I go shoot for 12 hours and
then I'll you know work out again during
the day but if I don't have to train
like that I'd rather just get up and
play normal goal what's your what's your
diet like you said you're eating chicken
but what's specifically like what like
if you get up at 3:00 in the morning
what are you eating egg whites Ezekiel
bread almond butter and then I'll work
out then I'll have yogurt and the street
yogurt and shake and then I'll have I'll
be half a chicken cooking Valley in a
rotisserie chicken then I'll eat turkey
burgers I don't eat a fish I eat
probably seven eight meals a day every
two and a half hours okay so clearly
sound like fun no no I mean actually
time it just sounds like you and I have
very different approaches I eat a lot of
Pizza
I would love to eat if I eat Eggo
waffles uh yeah you can actually make
them sandwiches you put anything you
want in between Sara will serve
everything with full syrup I and I try
to be good but then when I fall apart I
really fall apart well for me with the
jot you know whatever I have to do for
the job I'm so appreciative to be in
this position
ya know and I don't take it for granted
I'm the most prepared and always show up
early and uh willing to do anything I
need to to make sure that I'm good on
the part that's good what's working for
you I had a question which is it's
either that or driving a tow truck so
right I like that like movies but I mean
I take pride when I drove a tow truck as
well as nothing wrong with that but
right
I was curious because I've heard I think
will ferrell told me that you were the
fastest eater he's ever seen and I
wondered if because people have said the
same thing about me I grew up in a big
family and they put the food down and so
ie incredibly fast do you do that yes
absolutely I'm me being the youngest I
mean you had to fight for everything
that you got so I was just with a buddy
and we both had the same thing and he
said you're gonna eat later so what do
you mean I've already eaten and he was
two bites into a sandwich and I'm
already eating my sandwich and my salad
and drank my little protein shake but
right I'm always eating fast it I got I
got four kids so I'm always on the go
right right well I was just I'm just
glad that someone else is doing it too I
eat so fast that it actually irritates
everyone I'm with I'm ready to leave the
restaurant yeah he did I know my wife
people are happy with I've already
ordered and I'm like trying to get my
wife to order while we're in the car at
least tell me what she wants to eat
because she wants to sit down she'll
look at the menu she wants hear the
specials I mean we've been to these
places right fifty time we're creatures
have a go time same restaurant you know
what you're gonna order I mean yeah it's
the Olive Garden you know what you're
getting Nick up a menu let's look online
they'll see what the menu is I you know
I want to get in and out
you